[Musique]
bon je vous avoue que je suis un peu
saoulé là quand même parce que je
voulais me faire une partie de Jurassic
Park sauf que je viens de m'apercevoir
qu'on m'a rendu le mauvais jeu dans la
bonne boîte du coup ben Jurassic Park
allez à plus et comme il me reste plus
que ça sous la main c'est parti pour
[Musique]
waterw un jeu à licence ça vous évoque
quoi bon c'est vrai que maintenant les
jeux à licence ça fait vomir mais
pourtant le phénomène ne date pas d'hier
adopter des licences de blockbuster du
cinéma il est transformé en horreur
vidéoludique ça existait déjà il y a
longtemps Water World film sorti en
salle alors en 1995 avec Kevin kosner
film d'aventure et d'anticipation basé
sur un thème 1000 fois exploré de nos
jours mais totalement inédit à l'époque
voilà vous vous en souvenez et ben ici
on s'en fout parce que ça a aucune
importance dans le
scénario waterw est développé par
océan quoi vous attendeiez une blague ok
c'est parti tadan le soleil depuis
longtemps source de vie mais maintenant
source de d'mise je sais pas ce que
c'est s'entraîner à prendre l'anglais
ces jeux de merde quand même ou là
[ __ ] ça va vite nous y voilà donc
première réflexion je trouve que ça
ressemble assez à desrike sauf qu'à la
place d'un hélicoptère vous pilotez un
triarant et qu'à la place des iraakiens
vous dégommez des jet skis ouais non en
fait ça a rien à voir avec desk bon
c'est pas très évident à diriger puisque
les jet skis sont beaucoup plus mobiles
et beaucoup plus rapide que votre bateau
mais bon on est sur Super Nintendo c'est
pas une simulation réaliste du coup
votre trimarin il peut bouger freiner et
tourner comme s'il naviguait sur un
océan de
mayonnaise [ __ ] jamais ça finit ce
truc il y a aucun indicateur de
progression si un jeu PC j'aurais déjà
alt F4 en criant ça bugé ce truc ah ben
tiens voilà c'est
fini deuxème niveau enfin niveau c'est
un bonus stage mais ça vous le saurez
qu'à la fin parce que le problème dans
ce jeu c'est qu'on vous prévient jamais
alors là on est sous la flotte est en
train de nager il y a des objets
disséminés un peu partout et ils sont
tous différents on sait pas combien il
faut en prendre ni lesquels je prends
quoi le mug le crâne cette de table alle
je vais ramasser quelques-uns des fois
tuer les smokeers je pourrais toujours
les inviter à boire le thé on a une
barre de vie qui sert de barre d'oxygène
et il faut remonter avant qu'elle soit
vide parce que sinon on est
[Musique]
mort joie de gagner et le vainqueur de
la catégorie sérieux vous vous foutez de
moi et
pour je suis un homme AC grand je ne
peux pas respirer
sousau passons tout de suite à la
catégorie suivante celle des chemises
les plus moches le premier
nominé ok Encore un changement de
gameplay maintenant on passe au style
plateforme là on voit enfin votre héros
kevinner le but c'est de buter tous les
B les smokers comme dans le film le
compteur qui vous indique leur nombre en
haut à gauche et pour ça vous avez TR
vies alors tu as pas aimé Robin des Bois
prends ça contrairement à l'architecture
standard des jeux de plateforme où le
niveau a un début et une fin ici le
niveau n'a pas de fin on tourne en
boucle jusqu'au moment où on a buté le
dernier smokeer on est REM au départ
d'une machette on récupère
progressivement des armes sur les
ennemis attends mais je l' toucher là
[ __ ] c'est quoi cette machette à la
con là vous savez ça rappelle un peu la
galère d' astéx la machette qui a une
portée d'environ 12 cm vous prenez tout
le temps un coup avant de toucher
l'adversaire c'est vraiment de la
connerie quel intérêt d'avoir une
machette de cette taille si c'est pour
taper comme si ça avait l'amplitude d'un
couteau suisse ah voilà encore un truc
génial vous pouvez pas donner de coup de
machette accroupie alors que c'est
possible avec les flingues
allez et le vainqueur de la catégorie
c'est quoi ce délire et c'est bon on a
pigé heureusement les ennemis sont
incroyablement stupides ils se
contentent de faire des allers-retours
sur un chemin prédéfini sans tenir
compte de votre
bonjour excusez-moi vous auriez l'heure
non bon ben tant pis alors ah ben vous
Revoil t dé jeun question ah ben ok au
revoir alors hein et allez repêche au
canard franchement ce niveau il est
chiant mais d'une force prenez les
Tortues Ninja sur NES par exemple niveau
aquatique c'était une torture niveau
difficulté et ça a traumatisé toute une
génération de joueurs mais qui n'a pas
recommencé au moins 10 fois d'affilé bon
ok c'était [ __ ] de mais au moins il y
avait du challenge et tout le monde
voulait voir la suite et là regardez là
ça me saoule tellement je vais remonter
de
suite à la fin de chaque niveau on tombe
sur une boutique où on peut s'apercevoir
que les points amassés jusqu'à présent
servent à acheter des armes pour votre
bateau donc ça vous oblige à faire les
bonus stages à fond
merde vous pouvez acheter des armes pour
votre triarant et surtout vous pouvez le
réparer parce que vous ne récupérez pas
vos points de vie évidemment et si vous
oubliez c'est impossible de continuer
sans perdre
[Musique]
et allez retriarrant super bon ben sinon
des fois les smokers réussissent à
rentrer à l'intérieur de la tole pour
aller kidnapper des gens du coup pour
les libérer il faut exploser les jet
skis et des fois il y a un mec qui en
sort puttin je te jure le film il se
passe en 2500 les mecs qui vivent sur l'
tout de l'année ils savent pas nager
quoi ils auraient pu au moins faire
l'effort d'apprendre à nager en 500 ans
[ __ ] mais c'est pas vrai quoi j'ai des
jet skis des bombardiers des droyers des
horbord et maintenant il y a des
hydravions contre moi contre un pauvre
trimant quoi mais c'est bon allez là il
manque plus le Charles de GO les
sous-marins le krquin les requins géants
c'est bon allez on fait la
fête très sincèrement ça ressemble plus
à une bataille d'auto tamponneuse de
bate tamponneuse oh
laff bordel c'est pas vrai encore level
avec le trimarant non c'est quoi cette
merde là j'ai même pas récupéré mes
points de vie en plus
j'en ai marre c'est bon ce jeu il est
trop dur il est trop chiant pourquoi les
développeurs il faisaient des jeux comme
ça quand on était gosse franchement il
savais pas que adressa à des gamins ce
genre de truc allez c'est bon c'est bon
vas-y il encore un je tu finira pas quoi
quoi quoi tu veux le finir le jeu pas
moi le teste c'est à toi de le faire tu
veux que je le finisse ok allez c'est
parti je vais le finir le jeu vous allez
voir OK Mot de passe et on
recommence
[Musique]
le dernier boss
enfin
et voici une nouvelle perle de boss à
chier à rajouter dans ma collection
voilà maintenant c'est à moi maintenant
c'est à
toi vous enchaînez les trois mêmes
levels pendant des heures à défendre le
même Atol tuer les mêmes smokers
descendre des milliers de jet skis pour
ramasser les trois mêmes connards dans
l'eau qui savent toujours pas nager dans
quasiment les mêmes décor et finalement
vous finissez par le boss le plus facile
que j'ai jamais vu dans tous mes jeux
vidéos ce qui multiplie encore plus
votre frustration d'avoir fait tout ça
pour rien et maintenant préparez-vous à
voir la plus belle fin de votre
[Musique]
vie voilà bon bah c'était waterwor bon
cela dit le jeu est pas totalement à
jeté quand même hein je veux dire les
graphismes sont bien la musique est
correcte et l'animation est quand même
pas trop mal cela dit vous l'avez vu le
jeu est ennuyeux difficile mais
difficile à en crever c'est la limite de
l'infaisable et surtout il est répétitif
répétitif répétitif répétitif répétitif
répétitif voilà donc je veux dire c'est
pas parce qu'un jeu est bien emballé qui
va vous procurer des heures de fun et de
plaisir et ça c'est encore plus vrai
aujourd'hui bilan les jeux à licence
c'était pas mieux avant quant à toi j'en
ai pas encore
[Musique]
fini le dernier poisson chameau avec de
l'outre vient de disparaître il a été
retrouvé ce matin échoué sur l'une de
nos côtes d'après les premières analyses
il se serait étouffé en ingérant un jeu
vidéo jeté par un audio personnage
interrogé ce matin à ce sujet le
professeur sou a déclaré je cite
d'arrêter de jeter vos putaines d'ordure
de merde dans l'océan s'il vous plaît
merci voilà c'était les actualités de
ces dernières 24 heures passons tout de
suite au
news
[Musique]